Okay, so our topic today is that is a transaction.
So if you remember, you take admission anywhere, right?
So at the time of admission, you either have to pay the registration fee,
or you have to pay the token, right?
Or you have to pay the prospectus fees, etc.
Is this part clear?
So in our module, we have that particular option,
like we have set up in this.
So the last thing we covered was that
where will your application number come from?
After the application number, how will you make your stage?
What stage do you want?
After that, your admission sources are set.
Now the point is admission tags.
Okay, you understood the tags too.
The main thing is that now we have to make a transaction with the student
in some or the other use.
Whether it is your prospectus, whether it is your token money,
or whether it is your registration fees.
Because when you take admission, you have to pay some amount
for admission at that time.
Is it okay, Tanvi Baba?
Yes, sir.
So what do we have?
We have a transaction receipt setup.
First of all, we have to do that.
Let me tell you the reason.
Whenever you get a receipt,
it has a number written on it.
Right?
Yes, sir.
So that number is automatically generated from the receipt counter.
So what we do here is we set the receipt number here.
We need one, two.
You have to put a prefix for it.
For example, if this is the University of SDI,
then I have put SDI.
So after SDI, three, four,
whatever the counter update is,
it keeps changing.
So you have to set the receipt number here.
Anything can happen.
Sometimes the client tells the client,
sometimes we make it ourselves by taking their initiation.
And after that, the number starts from one.
Here it is already counter updated,
so it is coming from three.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
After that, we have admission heads.
Now what is your point?
If you want to collect from any student,
then you have to do this.
The collection can be in any random head.
It can be your registration,
your prospectus fees,
one of which is your pocket money.
I will tell you about the concept of pocket money later.
Before that, let's go to the direct test
for registration and prospectus fees.
Registration and prospectus fees.
I have put these two.
These are my two heads.
Now in this head, my transaction will come
and in this head, my transaction can come.
Now the point is,
where will this head's transaction come from?
So you had a stage setup
What we will do is,
if you want to collect
from any head,
from any particular stage,
then you will view that stage.
For example, my lead stage.
If I want my child to pay me money in my lead stage,
then I will view that stage.
After viewing, I will go to transactions.
From here, the transaction will be enabled.
So from here, my transaction will be enabled.
Is it clear?
After the transaction is enabled,
what I will do from here is
add transaction mapping.
Now while adding transaction mapping,
we have all the respective courses.
They all come here.
Which course do you want to do?
Which head do you want the amount in?
You will select that.
For example, I have selected this head.
I have selected your registration.
In registration,
what I am taking from the child is
that I have to take 100 rupees from this.
I have put 100 rupees.
For example, registration P.A.
Now what does the system do?
It shows you that
editable.
So basically what happens is
when you go for registration,
then some children are like this
whose registration is done in 1000 rupees.
Some children are like this whose registration is done in 200 rupees.
Am I right?
It depends on how much
you convince the institute
that we will be able to give this much.
So if you keep this editable,
then while collecting the amount
for registration,
the amount will be editable.
If you keep it fixed,
then it will be fixed there.
For now, let's take this editable.
I have turned on the editable.
Now you will not add each one manually.
You will select one course,
then you select one course, then you select registration,
then you select another course,
then you add the amount.
So what do we have?
We have the option of copy course head.
As soon as you copy the course head,
then what will the system do?
It will add all the other courses.
Is this clear, guys?
Now you have two things.
You can get the amount collected
in a single head at one stage.
But in one stage,
you can also clear the amount in multiple heads.
You can also take prospectus at the same stage.
You can also do that.
You have to take registration at one stage,
you have to take prospectus at one stage.
So what will we do?
We will take registration at one stage and prospectus at the other.
At the end, I have updated this.
So if I refresh it and get it checked,
then the transaction required here
will be on.
This transaction required is on.
Nothing is coming in this case.
Getting my point?
Yes, sir.
Now we have the next stage,
the data requested stage.
So what will we do at the data requested stage?
We will go to the registration.
We have added one head there.
We will add one head here, which is your prospectus.
It depends.
If we are doing this for testing,
we can add anything anywhere.
But the client will tell you which particular head
you have to keep at which stage.
What did I do in this case?
In this case, I kept it only non-editable.
I came,
clicked on update after the last one,
refreshed,
recording is on.
Now I came to the application data image.
This is my specific lead.
Take an example.
This is my lead stage.
My application is at the lead stage.
When I will view it,
then after viewing it, we put a thousand rupees there.
So I can collect
this thousand rupees from here.
I can collect this thousand rupees from here.
You have collected
this thousand rupees
payment mode.
You have collected this thousand rupees.
Which head did you go to?
This is your thousand rupees.
We have added registration.
Clear?
Yes, sir.
I have collected it.
Now I will move it to the next stage.
I have collected
this thousand rupees.
I have collected this thousand rupees.
I have collected this thousand rupees in my transaction.
I have got my counter,
its receipt.
I came down, clicked on next,
clicked on update.
Now what will I do?
I can't go to the next stage,
the approved stage,
until I collect this thousand rupees.
I will collect this thousand rupees from here.
I clicked on save.
Now
I have collected this thousand rupees in my prospectus.
I have collected this thousand rupees from here.
I can understand
where this came from,
I can understand these things.
Yes, sir.
We made a stage for this.
We have set the amount in that stage.
Now we have, last but not least,
when we go to the next stage,
we have another one thousand rupees
for collection, which we have set in this.
In your admission,
in the last stage,
in the registration stage.
We have set 1100 rupees in the registration stage.
This entity table is on.
The head is not coming here.
Let's do one thing.
For this, let's make a separate head.
Because it is from the old one,
so let's keep this.
Registration is done, prospectus is done.
Let's keep the voucher.
Keep that too.
Let's keep the visit piece.
That kid is visiting,
that's why Steve East is giving it to him.
You go to the next stage.
After going to the next stage,
you open the same stage.
Then you have the transaction.
What do we do in the transaction?
We delete everything.
And we add the single head,
which we have just made.
Because new courses are coming.
What I will do is,
I will go to add mapping.
Select the head and put it in the visit fee, 1100 rupees.
I saved it here.
This amount is ready.
I have copied everything.
And I will edit it at the end.
What was my first stage?
It was my lead stage.
In that lead stage, we collected 1000 rupees.
Which was in our registration.
Then the next stage was
our data request stage.
On which you collected 1200 rupees.
Am I right?
From there, you collected 1200 rupees.
Now my last stage is,
where we are collecting one more amount from the child.
That amount is yours.
Next stage, you removed it.
One thing you noticed,
we had editables there.
Now I can edit it.
I can pay as much as I want.
In the previous one, we kept the editables off.
So we couldn't edit there.
If you remember,
only this one was coming.
From here, I collected 11 rupees.
I collected 11 rupees in the visit fee.
From here, I collected 11 rupees in the visit fee.
Now what is the point?
Understand this thing.
We have done the registration.
On this stage, we have collected it.
I will show you in the view transaction.
You collected 1000 rupees, 1200 rupees,
and then you collected 1200 rupees.
The transaction part is clear.
How to set up?
How the head will be made?
At what stage will the head be made?
Is that thing clear?
Yes sir.
Is the meaning of amount editable clear?
What does it mean to turn on the amount editable?
Is it clear?
Yes sir.
If your editable is enabled,
then you can go there and edit the amount
and collect it.
If your editable is not enabled,
then you can collect the amount set there.
Now we have
one more thing.
That is your save zero amount transaction.
What happens in save zero amount transaction?
I will tell you a small thing.
Suppose you have turned on
the amount editable.
Now the user
who is collecting the payment
has put zero amount and collected it.
That is wrong.
Zero amount is not needed
to collect it.
Yes sir.
So in that case,
we will turn on the save zero amount transaction.
After that,
they can save the transaction by zero.
We are bypassing it.
Some students
don't need to pay the registration fee.
If they don't need it,
then we can't define it student wise.
So we have made a structure
in which we have turned it on.
If any student
wants to take zero amount,
then they can put zero amount and
make the transaction.
Now I will show you something.
Let's turn on the is editable.
And we will keep it off at zero.
Let's check the BTEK lead.
We have turned on the is editable.
Now we will
pick a specific course.
This is the one.
This is my study.
I have saved it in the next stage.
In the first stage,
we are taking a free payment
because we have not turned on the is editable.
I have saved it.
In the next stage,
I have come to the registration.
I have filtered it.
I have to check the transaction history.
You can see all the transaction history from here.
So remember this too.
I have opened it.
I have collected 1000 rupees.
In the next stage,
I have turned on the is amount editable.
If I pay zero here,
then the system will not allow me to pay zero.
If I pay zero here, then the system will not allow me to pay zero.
Amount can't be zero.
Please enter a valid amount to proceed.
Did you understand?
Yes, sir.
Now if I go there
and turn on the is amount editable
in the zero amount save transaction.
and turn on the is amount editable.
I have updated it.
I have finished it.
I have gone to the application data.
I have deleted it.
In the next stage,
if I zero it,
then it will allow me to save it.
Now I can take its zero amount transaction.
Did you understand what is zero amount enable?
We have collected zero in this.
First it did not allow me to collect.
Is it clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
Try to understand one thing.
The transaction part is clear.
You have to take registration fees.
You have to take prospectus fees.
You have to collect random xyz amount.
Whatever registration fee you pay,
or whatever prospectus fees you pay,
Registration can be adjusted in your fees.
But the money you pay to the other heads,
it does not get adjusted anywhere.
It goes directly to their accounts.
Suppose you have a fee of 1 lakh rupees.
When you went for registration or admission,
they said that we need
Rs.2500 or Rs.5000
for prospectus.
You gave Rs.5000.
That will not be less than 1 lakh.
That is a different amount.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
So, if we want a head
whose amount is less,
that means,
you gave me a token money.
Suppose I have a fee of 1 lakh rupees.
I am getting admission now.
My registration or prospectus fees
will be different.
But I have an extra amount
in the name of token money
which will be adjusted in my fees.
So, we have a head
of direct token money.
It is directly selected.
You do not make it.
You saved it.
This is the head of token money.
Is it clear?
Now, what we will do is
we need to take the token money
at any stage.
Usually, we take it at the last stage.
Suppose we take the token money at the last stage.
I went for this.
I added another head of token money.
I put Rs.10,000 in this.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
I saved it.
So, basically,
when I collect the fees
of this particular head,
I went to the data requested.
I collected 0 in the first one.
I collected 1100 in the first one.
Now, the point is
I have Rs.11,100.
Why?
Because our Rs.11,100
was already added
as a visit fee.
And we added Rs.10,000 more
in the token money.
So, what did he make combined?
What did he make combined?
Rs.11,100.
He adjusted it.
It hasn't been adjusted yet.
We have summed it.
Now, we will collect all this.
We have collected Rs.11,000 from him.
We have collected Rs.11,100 from the child.
Now, this money has gone into two things.
It has gone into the visit fee
and the token money.
Now, what is the point?
You gave the money Rs.11,100.
Okay.
But when the child's admission is approved
then the system automatically
adjusts Rs.10,000
out of the amount of Rs.1,00,000.
Do you understand?
Let me show you.
Let's make the fee structure of this child.
Let's say I added the tuition fee.
Rs.1,00,000.
Okay.
I added the tuition fee of Rs.1,00,000.
Now, basically what will happen is
when I approve this child
Now, when I approve this child
who lives here
approve
give the number to the child
for now, I have added the test.
Okay.
Click on save.
Now, the child is being approved.
It means the admission is done.
Now, we are adding it in the student list.
Oh no, I didn't even add DO. Sorry.
Okay.
Basically, guys, what happens is
you don't add the student manually.
You already have the data
so you are transferring it from one module to another.
Okay.
Now, let me show you one thing.
When you go to the student list
and search for the test student
we added this.
When you go to the fee collection
and collect the fee
we added the fee of Rs.1,00,000.
Okay. How much was the total fee?
Rs.1,00,000.
Yes or no?
Yes, sir.
Okay. How much was the payable?
It should have been Rs.1,00,000.
But what did it do?
It gave Rs.10,000 for token money.
So, when we approved the child
and added it in the student list
the system reduced its Rs.10,000
from its net balance.
Now, it has to pay only Rs.90,000.
Are things getting clear?
Token money and the difference in it
is getting clear?
Yes, sir. It is clear.
So, this is how it is understood
that the token money that you have
will always be adjusted
in its fees.
The other heads that you have
they get collected directly.
They don't have anything to adjust
in your fees. Is that okay, guys?
Yes, sir.
Perfect. Now, tell me
if there is any doubt
where the head will be added
and why we have to set the receipt counter
for the transaction.
After that, in stage setup
what is the meaning of editable?
What is the meaning of
save zero amount transaction
in editable?
Is this clear?
Yes, sir. It is clear.
I am still
repeating things.
Basically, when you take admission
you have to pay some amount.
To pay the amount
you have to have a head as well.
When you pay the fee, you have tuition fee
uniform fee, examination fee
etc.
At the time of admission, you have
registration fee, prospectus fee
these are different heads.
So, here we make heads
in our admission head.
We also have
token money in it.
We don't have to add the token money
separately and it is not editable.
It is removed from here.
Then comes the receipt counter.
Now, when your transactions
will continue
then you need
some kind of counter.
7, 8, 5, 2, 3, 1
whatever you need.
Your receipt needs a number.
So, we set the number
in transaction receipt setup.
Clear?
Guys?
After that,
what happens is
we go to our stage setup
and at the stage
in which I have to collect
I go to the stage
and set it.
Suppose, I need something at the first stage
I need another head at the second stage
I need multiple heads at the same stage
then that is also possible.
Like we did in this
data required
in registration
transaction
two heads are set together.
We can also do different things for different courses.
For example, in this course
we are only taking the visit fee
and in this course we are taking both.
So, what will the system do?
As soon as the child is approved
after collecting the payment
the token money will be adjusted
and the rest of the fees will only be visible to you.
Is it clear guys?
Yes.
This was all about your
transaction and token money.